if you were to call this assassin bug
bloodthirsty the bug would most likely
say huh and your point is practically
from the moment of birth in a cave in
southern Belize the assassin bug has one
mission to suck another creatures blood
take this newly hatched assassin bug
baby called a nymph to grow the nymph
must have the blood of a vertebrate and
so the nymphs first act after finding
its legs is to go vertebrate hunting
Fisher reptile will do
but the neuf was born near a cave that
is home for both fruit bats and vampire
bats this sleeping fruit bat will do
nicely
the nymph can sense its victims body
heat it punctures the bats wingtip with
its needle-like nose and then to fill
her up like a gasoline tanker truck
filling with fuel the new gorges itself
it's saliva acts as an anesthetic
the bat feels no pain in another part of
the cave a vampire bat pop is in trouble
she slid down a cave wall attracting
some adult assassin bugs the bugs have
cornered a pup on a Ledge and aim the
blood sucking siphons right at her the
pup can't fly it but she can use her
forearms and legs to escape the assassin
bugs don't give up they go after the pup
maybe they should learn from their own
nips getting a meal is so much easier
when your prey is asleep